[Musique]
bonsoir antoine sfeir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce sont les
premiers responsables politiques être
accusé dans cette affaire c'est un
tournant bonsoir effectivement c'est un
tournant oui vous savez le liban est
dans une tourmente d'économie politique
sur le blanc des affaires sociales et
puis à vue ce crime contre l'humanité le
4 août dernier qui a vraiment secoué le
pays et le corps économique du pays
effectivement le juge d'instruction
auprès de la cour de justice a pris une
position aujourd'hui c'est un tournant
juridique et politique en même temps
juridique parce que irrite pas mal de
humeur d'infos de fausses infos que le
juge n'a pas pris de position jusqu'ici
1 et des mois écoulés il ya des gens
blessés il ya d'autres fuyaient vous
savez actuellement il a pris cette
position
ça a commencé à donner un sérieux plus
solide et plus consolidée a à l'esprit
qu'à l'instruction à lanquais à tout ce
qui est jusqu'à la pole avec les
mécanismes juridiques et judiciaires
sur le plan politique je vous dis
franchement c'est pas facile qu'un
premier ministre sortant mais qui est
toujours en fonction voulu qu'ils aiment
paris encore un gouvernement un
gouvernement suite au tollé les troubles
politiques qui secouent le pays
actuellement c'est une décision
c'est une première qu'un juge
d'instruction plie de la cour de justice
a pris position contre le planning liste
et toi ministère des travaux publics
c'est un tournant il ya une polémique
sur le plan juridique ici si les
présidents et les ministres selon
transféré devant la cour spéciale pour
le jugement des milices des présidents
au palais du parlement qui n'a jamais
fonctionné d'ailleurs elle qui a acquis
qu'ils savaient répète qu'à luxe le plan
fonctionnel ou bien ils sont selon
transféré devant lui
le juge lui même et c'est la justice et
le pouvoir judiciaire qui va voir tout
ça observé plantes position suite aux
enquêtes qui vont avoir eu un premier
ministre responsable mais pas coupable
est ce que c'est ce qui risque de se
passer lors de ce procès pourra prendre
une phrase célèbre d'un ancien ministre
français
il ya vraiment une part évident de
responsabilité dans cette affaire de la
part de l'ex premier ministre libanais
selon vous en tant qu'avocat je veux pas
dire s'il est coupable ou non en tant
qu'avocat je veux observer de loin car
j'ai pas les informations précises et
les détails de l'enquète mais je veux
vous dire que même si le plus misé sur
temps fut accusée par le club par le
juge d'instruction aujourd'hui ça veut
pas dire qu'il est coupable peut-être y
avait des soucis des éclaircissements
des et les relations à faire peut-être
il a été accusé puis il y aura des infos
qui vont être les cibles dans quel
talent c'est un c'est un long processus
c'est pas facile de de prouver que le
premier ministre sortant ehoud par duke
il n'a qu'elle n'a vécu au pouvoir s'il
voulait en guinée au palais du
gouvernement que quelques mois alors ça
c'est une première question la seconde
question il ya
depuis quelques jours une accusation
compte des ancêtres à jeter à l'eau
couler la base de l'enrichissement
c'est à dire suivant des d enquête de
corruption
c'est le même principe aussi c'est qu'il
ya des points d'interrogation sur ce
plan si quelqu'un est accusé il ya des
fondement juridique et des faits bien
précis et concis alors ils doivent être
arrêtés
sinon ce sont des accusations en paix
mais on vante des accusations je peux
pas dire plus maintenant on doit
s'attendre à des enquêtes plus élargie à
des polémiques politiques de tous bords
pour relancer ou donner un peu plus
sérieux au orale enquête c'est un crime
contre l'humanité et c'est pas moi qui
dis ça c'est sont les réalités
c'est il ya des centaines qui ont vu
qu'ils ont été tuées et il ya tout un
pays qui a été mal utilisées alors il
faut qu'il y ait une enquête sérieuse
sinon
or d'organisation beaucoup des familles
de victimes qui vont aller qui vont
demander de plus en plus des enquêtes
indépendantes ou internationa dernière
question rapidement peut-on faire
confiance en la justice on a eu des
invités et c'est qu'ils nous disaient
voilà on doute quand même de
l'indépendance de la justice et et qu'il
y ait vraiment un résultat fiable ce que
vous le pensez au sujet effectivement
tant que juriste tant que politologue
que je peux vous dire que j'ai confiance
en quelques juges on n'a pas confiance
dans un système pourri la système ici
c'est que la politique est bien
omniprésente au niveau de justice au
liban
c'est pour cela dans les brousses et de
corruption qu'on n'a pas vu aucun aucune
personne aucun personnage politique du
monde de la justice de l'arrestation qui
a été emprisonné et ça c'est une grande
question aussi mais avec la lutte du des
jeunes du liban avec la le support de la
communauté nationale
on va voir un jour certains mais ce jour
ça va nous coûter beaucoup plus merci
beaucoup en train de se faire avocat
merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous